مدفع قيصر الذي تنتجه شركه نيكسترا
الفرنسيه كان واحد من اهم مدافع كما وقعت
الشركه المنتجه له على عده عقود لبيعه
لعدد من الدول حول العالم سواء داخل او
خارج اوروبا هذا طبعا بالاضافه الى منتجات
اخرى تقدمها شركه نيكستر الفرنسيه من
بينها مدافع وذخائر وعتاد عسكري اسلحه
جعلت نيكستر واحده من اهم اللاعبين في سوق
الدفاع العالمي اليوم للحديث عن اهم
منتجات الشركه وبرامجها هنا في المنطقه
معنا في الاستوديو المدير الاقليمي لشركه
نيكستر الفرنسيه السيد دومينيك اولا مستر
ديمونيك اهلا بك معنا في الاستوديو وشكرا
على وجودك معنا يعني يبدو ان مدفع القيصر
الذي تقدمونه في نيكستر متى يحظى باهتمام
كبير على مستوى العالم خاصه بعد الحرب في
اوكرانيا وما حققه من شهره كبيره لكن الى
اي مدى هناك اهتمام هنا في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط بمدفع القيصر وما الذي يميزه عن
غيره من مدافع
مساء الخير بدايه اود ان اشكرك على الدعوه
لاستضافه في برنامجكم اليوم كما تعلمون
فان نكستر هي شركه دفاعيه فرنسيه من
الاكبر في فرنسا واوروبا في مجال تصميمي
وتطوير وتصنيع معدات الدفاع البري فان
نظرنا الى ما يحدث في اوكرانيا نجد ان
هناك حاجه ماسه لحمايه الفرق العسكريه
وتوفير الذخيره لها وما يميز مدفع قيصر
سهوله الاستخدام واحتياجاته اللوجستيه
قليله كما انه سهل التحريك والنقل ولديه
قدره على اطلاق طلقات متعدده في الدقيقه
الواحده والتواضع في دقيقه ومغادره المكان
في دقيقه وهي طريقه جيده لتجنب المواجهات
مع العدو وهذا ما يجعل قيصر مدفعا حديثا
جدا وناجحا جدا للاستخدام في ساحات
المعارك لكن فيما يتعلق باهتمام دول
المنطقه بمدفع القيصر
مدافع قيصر موجوده في المنطقه وكما تعلمون
فان واحده من الدول الكبرى في المنطقه
اشترت بالفعل عددا لا باس به من مدافع
قيصر ووصلنا رد فعل ايجابي منهم عن
استخدامه وكفاءاته كما ان القوات الفرنسيه
لديها اتفاقيات دفاعيه مع عدد من دول
المنطقه وهي تستخدم القيصر في تعاون
العسكري ونحن في نكستر نقدم خدمات الدعم
لعملائنا وبالنسبه للمنطقه فان جميع
عملائنا هنا يحاولون تلبيه احتياجاتهم
الجديده ونحن كشركه تجاريه نحاول ان نقدم
لهم افضل ما لدينا من تكنولوجيا لتلبيه
احتياجات هؤلاء العملاء
الرئيس الفرنسي منويل المكرو المحا مؤخرا
بامكانيه ارسال عدد من دبابات لوكليرك
التي تقدمونها في نيكستر الى الاوكرانيين
ان حدث هذا الامر هل تعتقد بانه الدبابات
مؤهله للتعامل مع ظروف المناخيه وكذلك
التضاريس الصعبه في اوكرانيا
من المهم الاشارات الى اننا هنا في هذه
المنطقه قد اعددناك بمواصفات خاصه لهذه
المنطقه وقد حصلت عليها الامارات لتصبح
بمواصفات خليجيه لتتناسب مع الصحراء ومن
المهم لاشارته هنا الى ان التصميم الاساسي
لدبابات مخصص لاواسط اوروبا وشرقها
وبالتالي فان التصميم الفرنسيه يتلائم مع
الطبيعه الاوروبيه لا شك في ذلك بالعوده
لسؤالك فنحن كشركه موجودون لدعم عملائنا
سواء فرنسا او الامارات او الاردن فالاردن
لديه بعض دبابات لوكلاخ ومهمتنا هي دعم
عملائنا قدر الامكان مصر التهديدات التي
تواجه اوروبا تختلف بشكل او باخر عن
التهديدات التي تواجهها دول منطقه الشرق
الاوسط انتم في نكسر ما هي اهم المنظومات
التي تعتقدون انها مناسبه للتعامل
والتعاطي مع التهديدات التي تواجهها بعض
دول المنطقه وتتناسب كذلك مع الطبيعه
الجغرافيه لهذه الدول عايزين
منذ بدايتنا في نكستر ونحن ناخذ بعين
الاعتبار اسواق تصدير عندما نضع تصميماتنا
واهم مواصفات انظمه نكستر هي سرعتها
ودقتها وقدرتها على حمايه طواقمها فمن
المهم ان تعيد ابناء الوطن سالمين وهناك
فرص عديده في المنطقه والسوق لا يتوقف على
منتج او على فقط بلدينا مجالات عديده
للتطوير مع عدد من دول المنطقه وهناك
امكانيات كبيره للتعاون
سبق
استراتيجيه بعض الدول الان في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط تغيرت لم تعد تبحث فقط عن شراء
معدات عسكريه ولكن كذلك تبحث عن مشاركه
التكنولوجيا ومشاركه الافكار مع الشركات
والدولي الكبرى العامله في هذا المجال
ولديها خبره كبيره في هذا المجال بالفعل
هناك الكثير من الشركات الاوروبيه
والامريكيه الكبرى العامله بدات يعني
تتعاون في هذا المجال مع بعض دول المنطقه
انتم في نكسر الى اي مدى انتم مستعدون
للمشاركه مع دول المنطقه في هذا المجال
بالطبع من اجل نجاح في هذه الدول علينا
نقل بعض النشاطات ونقوم بنوعين من توطين
النشاط اولهما توطين الصناعه وسلاسل
الامداد قدر الامكان عندما يكون في ذلك
جدوى اقتصاديه وهنا في الامارات كان مستوى
الاستثمار الذي تم تنفيذه في السنوات
العشر الاخيره قادرا على جعل الامارات
شريكا كفئا نحن نرحب بشراكه مع الشركات
المحليه لتحضير للمستقبل وهذه فرص
مستقبليه نجهز لها كما نتعاون بشكل وثيق
مع المجلس الاقتصادي لتحقيق النجاح فنحن
نلتزم بتنفيذ تلك المشروعات التي اتفقنا
عليها مسبقا هذا بالنسبه للامارات اما
بالنسبه للسعوديه فمن المؤكد ان التعاون
مع السعوديه اساسي
لمستقبلنا في المنطقه سواء في مجال
الدبابات او الاسلحه او الذخيره فهويتنا
كشركه تشمل تعاون مع هؤلاء الشركاء